here are three reasons I use kit.com
over beehive one is deliverability kit
has way more likelihood to actually land
your emails in your reader primary inbox
because they have a better sender
reputation because they've been around
for a lot longer and I've sent way more
emails where beehive is way more
designheavy and they often land in
promotions and spam two is Simplicity
beehive ships a new feature every single
week that I guarantee you're not going
to use honestly you really just need
tags sequences and broadcast that's it
everything else is a distraction and
number three is organic list growth
beehive really focuses on like ad
Network ad sponsorships and paid
sponsorships which usually leads to
really lowquality subscribers or
lowquality traffic where people don't
even remember why they got on your list
where kit.com really focuses on
recommendations and Creator Network
which is a which is an organic way for
you to meet other people and organically
people see your list which leads to
higher quality subscribers